[Musik]
fruchtaufstrich und erdbeer shake bei
diesen produkten kann ordentlich
getrickst werden wie frische erdbeeren
da am ende noch im produkt landen und
was überhaupt als marmelade verkauft
werden darf zeigt durch sebastian leger
[Musik]
erdbeeren aber nicht so viel erdbeeren
auch nicht soviel erdbeeren sondern so
viel erklären
um so viel check zu machen
zeit zum zaubern wir fangen an zu
schenken wir nehmen das wasser
neben unsere farbe von der rote beete
milchpulver bei so wenig erdbeere
schmeckt natürlich noch nicht nach
erdbeere sondern jetzt schmeckt gleich
nach erdbeeren
[Musik]
möglichst preisgünstige zutaten und
chemie für den geschmack
[Musik]
um das ganze vollmundig cremig zu machen
setzen wir bindemittel ein
das ganze machen wir jetzt auch noch
zuckersüß ansonsten wird der pc kann er
besteht
von lassen langsam in zucker einrieseln
es sieht aus wie apple
es riecht wie er wäre
es schmeckt nach erdbeere ist aber nur
so viel er wäre nach diesem prinzip kann
man gesunde aber teure zutaten sparen
und wie sieht es bei fruchtaufstrichen
aus wird hier an erdbeeren gespart
tatsächlich sind fruchtaufstriche wahre
wundertüte
es gibt keine vorgaben woraus sie genau
bestehen müssen
dagegen ist besonders streng geregelt
die konfitüre extra die muss mindestens
45 prozent frucht enthalten außerdem
liegt der gesamt zuckergehalt wegen der
haltbarkeit bei mindestens 55 prozent
alles geregelt in der deutschen
konfitüren verordnung bei der
herstellung von fruchtaufstrichen
dagegen gibt es solche vorschriften
nicht was alles möglich ist wenn auf
einmal alles erlaubt ist das zeigt
produktentwickler sebastian läge hier
haben wir die kleine mischmasch party
der fruchtaufstrich reinhauen was wir
wollen ob johannisbeere fruchtsäfte im 1
habe sogar eine möhre gefunden da gibst
du namen wie green compose ich meine ist
das schon wort wo man morgens auch schon
gleich ganz harmonisch wird oder
sebastian lege macht einen erdbeer
fruchtaufstrich mit nur wenig roten
früchten
dafür umso mehr karottensaft konzentrat
und ganz viel aus dem lebensmittellabor
ich würde mal sagen
simsalabim bei seinem fruchtaufstrich
ist einfach alles erlaubt billige möhren
zum strecken und ein paar johannisbeeren
für die säure konfitüre darf sich das
nicht mehr nennen
das reicht aber jetzt auch an erdbeeren
weil wir haben noch sirup wir haben noch
aroma wir haben noch saft alles
ordentlich vermissen und anschließend
mit etwas sirup für den geschmack und
saft für die farbe auf diesen fertig es
die grundmasse das video schon ganz
interessant aus unser bären süppchen
erdbeer fruchtaufstrich richtung rück
nicht so schlecht das ganze jetzt ich
sie einmal aufkochen lassen etwas
konzentrierter zitronensaft ordentlich
süßen und damit die suppe auch
irgendwann fest wird eine mutige dosis
von bindemittel pektin und was es mit
dem karotten geschmack auch dagegen gibt
das richtige mittel wirklich nicht und
das muss noch nicht einmal von der
erdbeere stammen das kann auch aus holz
stoffen gewonnen werden und darf dennoch
natürliches aroma heißen
und ab in den kühlschrank zwei stunden
später ist es soweit
sie ist kalt geworden sie doch ganz gut
aus fertig ist unsere app erfuhr sie
einfach im fruchtaufstrich wo alles drin
sein darf
da steht dem landtags früheste gern
nichts mehr im weg und wie schmeckt
also wer süß mag noch tages erdbeeraroma
ich schon echt krass ein erdbeer
fruchtaufstrich mit wenig erdbeeren
dafür aber mit vielen anderen zutaten
aus der trickkiste des produktentwickler
fruchtaufstriche sind also eine neue
produktkategorie die den herstellern
viele freiheiten ermöglichen wie sehr
machen sie davon gebrauch und gibt es
einen unterschied zwischen ihm und
merkel bei zentis und schwartau reicht
der frucht anteil von 45 bis zu 75
prozent
die noname cent halten mindestens 50
prozent frucht und sind deutlich
billiger
am besten schneiden aldi süd und nord
sowie lidl ab 75 prozent erdbeeren für
je nur 99 cent
aber achtung fruchtaufstriche können
auch anders
speziell für kinder setzt zentis hier
auf günstigen karottensaft und kommt auf
einen frucht anteil von nur noch rund 40
prozent ergebnis in unserer stichprobe
bei 9 ems gibt es mehr frucht für
weniger geld
habt ihr einen fruchtaufstrich favoriten
oder macht er sie sogar selber sagt es
uns in den kommentaren
und wenn ihr noch mehr über eure
lebensmittel wissen wollt schaut in die
nächsten zwei clips und abonniert die
zdf besser esser
[Musik]